[Musique]
aujourd'hui jeudi 17 mars l'actualité
dans les yvelines un premier
entraînement à un millier de kilomètres
de chez eux cinq joueurs ukrainiens et
leur entraîneur ont pu rechausser les
crampons ce matin sur la pelouse de l'as
football fois ci le club de nationale 2
les accueille sous l'impulsion de son
président lui même d'origine ukrainienne
pour la troisième année consécutive
sébastien perron nos professeurs de
mathématiques à saint germain en les
lançant des filles pour son veau crypto
challenge il s'intéresse à ada lovelace
une comtesse à l'origine de la machine
analytique plusieurs niveaux de jeu sont
proposés
touché par deux concerts successifs et
aujourd'hui guérir et avec un remy a
décidé d'en rire dans son one woman show
good life cette amoureuse de la scène
est actuellement en résidence à vulaines
sur seine pour peaufiner les derniers
détails nous l'avons rencontré lors
d'une répétition
[Musique]
c'est le top départ pour la sixième
édition de la job academy lancée par la
fondation face yvelines dix demandeurs
d'emploi vont être mises en binôme avec
un professionnel du château de
versailles objectif retrouver une
employabilité à travers de l'ecoute du
soutien ou encore de l'accompagnement
c'est un contrat que l'on signe en trois
ou quatre mois avec apparat une fiole le
filleul s'engageant à rencontrer
régulièrement le parrain pour améliorer
à la fois son cv tous ces critères de
recherche
d'emploi des agents du château de
versailles de tous les secteurs de tous
les départements du château de
versailles qui vont dans trois mois
travailler avec eux pour
envisager leur nouvelle vie la vie
d'après la vie après une rupture une
secousse rendre son cv plus attractifs
ne pas perdre ses moyens pendant un
entretien s'y retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux les binômes se retrouveront au
minimum une fois tous les quinze jours
pendant trois mois pour différents
ateliers aujourd'hui c'était la première
rencontre entre francis et son parrain
il avancé l'essor des études donc on va
voir comment on peut me les mes contacts
en cybersécurité en ingénierie
informatique
et voir qu'est-ce qu'on pourra
travailler avec lui on va essayer déjà
de se présenter à l'oral
et de développer les compétences et
capacités l'idée très sympa donc en plus
ses hobbies correspond à roumieh donc on
a discuté en vue de discuter juste il ya
un instant j'espère que cette expérience
va me permettre d'avoir
un beau parcours professionnel
de messer professionnellement dans le
monde du travail également
progresser en compétences depuis 2000 15
71 personnes ont déjà été accompagnée
70% des personnes suivies retrouve en
emploi après six mois cette année la
promotion vise les 100 %
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
il
l'avion français
il s'appelle romane oleksandr jaroslaw
ou encore consciente in ce sont des
joueurs de football ukrainien avec leur
entraîneur jury yaroshenko ils viennent
d'arriver à poissy ils sont accueillis
ici à cause de la guerre en ukraine en
leur honneur le président du club de
football et le maire karl olive ont
organisé une cérémonie l'idée c'est
qu'ils assouvissent leurs patients qui
continue à jouer et puis moi j'avais 6
ans et 10 ans deux mois et que dans
trois mois c'est la fin de la guerre je
serai le plus heureux des hommes on la
mettra dans l'avion on rappellera les
billets d'avion et on partira sûrement
la larme à l'oeil mais avec un gros
sourire tout ce qui me qui m'anime à moi
en tout cas la première des actions que
je mets en place maintenant c'est de
demander à l'état et à la fédération
française de football d'accorder des
licences rapidement pour que ces jeunes
ces jeunes puissent jouer les évolue en
deuxième division ukrainienne ça va nous
faire du bien
[Musique]
footballeur professionnel de lipova
dolina club de deuxième division
ukrainienne ils se sont tout de suite
mis dans le bain un premier entraînement
avec les joueurs pisciacais évolue en
quatrième division c'est une fierté
parce que l'on montre qu'on est là pour
aider les gens et que que le footsie
césar c'est partage c'est envie d'aider
les autres on se met à leur place et
c'est pas facile pour eux on vit à
travers les réseaux sociaux par ce qui
se passe pas à la télé on voit ce qui se
passe et c'est franchement pas évident
qu'après ne sont pas apportées à notre
manière le fait qu'ils puissent venir
s'entraîner avec nous et les mettre dans
les meilleures dispositions d'ici
position les gestes techniques sont
fluides les connexions entre les joueurs
paraissent naturelles malgré la
différence de langue français et
ukrainiens se comprennent
dans le langage du football il n'y a pas
besoin de traduire cet universel
le football c'est tout dans ma vie et je
suis très content de pouvoir m'entraîner
ici à poissy en france avec l'équipe
les joueurs ont une bonne qualité de jeu
un bon niveau on voit qu'il joue au
football depuis longtemps ils ont la
qualité technique et ils sont forts et
le coach pisciacais walid haïchour
propose même à son homologue ukrainien
d'animer une séance d'entraînement ce
lundi sera deux jours après le match et
c'est pas une idée n'est que devrait
tenir pour les jo samedi à nice votre
signe vous ferez
basé sur la technique si celle ci est
unique c'est
[Musique]
l'équivalent de 40 poids lourds c'est le
résultat de la collecte organisée par
des commune yvelinoise à destination du
peuple ukrainien des dons récupéré par
les villes puis rassemblés par le
département les dernières communes ont
transmis leurs dons ces derniers jours
comme la ville de mantes-la-jolie ce
jeudi 17 mars le département organisera
aussi le 8 avril prochain un concert au
château de versailles pour collecter des
fonds pour la cause ukrainienne
990 mètres cubes partent pour
montigny-le-bretonneux dans le lieu de
stockage mis à disposition par le
département soixante neuf autres
communes envoie du matériel et ce
matériel vont ce matin va être pardon
acheminés vers l'ukraine par deux
partenaires la protection civile et
l'association act raid donc c'est les
lums générosité démentait ici à mantes
mais de tous les yvelinois en faveur de
ces enfants de ces femmes de ses
habitants de ce pauvre pays
[Musique]
le crypto challenge c'est donc un jeu
dédié autour des codes secrets on a des
textes qui sont cryptés d'une certaine
manière ou lélex les lettres sont
interchanger et le but est de retrouver
le texte originel à partir d'un 10
cette année il y a un tout un jeu
d'énigmes autour d'une figure
scientifique s'appelle ada lovelace et
le crypto challenge ne consiste plus
uniquement à décrypter des textes qui
n'ont rien à voir les uns les autres
mais à avancer sous une forme de jeu de
piste à del vallès une figure qui est un
méconnu des des sciences c'est une
comtesse qui était très doué en
mathématiques
c'était la première moitié du 19e siècle
et elle a travaillé sur une machine
sur les plans d'une machine qui
s'appelle la machine analytique qui est
considéré un peu comme l'ancêtre de
l'ordinateur
je me suis dis bah je vais pas en faire
profiter que mes élèves puisque c'est
quelque chose qui se passe sur internet
et je vais l'ouvrir à tout public
enfants et adultes
[Musique]
oui rebecca rumi a connu la maladie et
deux fois même trois si l'on compte la
spina bifida
malformations sur la colonne vertébrale
avec laquelle elle née mais de ce
parcours médical elle a choisi d'en rire
d'en faire rire j'ai un humour un peu
dans la dérision farkas tique un peu
humour noir j'ai pas peur de me moquer
de moi même je connais les hôpitaux du
pcci petit et d'ailleurs je le dis dans
mon spectacle les hôpitaux font ma
résidence secondaire ce que j'y ai passé
beaucoup de temps dessus du de cancer un
lymphome et le féminin greffe de moelle
osseuse avec moins d'heures life rebecca
a fait le choix d'écrire son histoire la
chimio les effets secondaires des
traitements mais pas de pathos pour
celle qui a fait l'école du one man show
à paris c'est vraiment quelque chose que
j'ai écrit avec mon coeur
qui me confirme qu' une partie de ma vie
j'ai une ville et un petit peu atypique
je dirais que c'est un peu ma thérapie
théâtrale et j'ai fait de délivrer un
message aux gens c'est à dire que même
si on a des ennuis dans la vie que sa
foi des petits comme des gros tracas ou
des épreuves difficiles bien il faut
toujours garder espoir qu'on peut s'en
sortir que la médecine n'est pas une
science exacte écrit pendant trois ans
après sa rémission est rendu aussi
difficile par la crise de lakovic under
life et mis en scène par delphine grand
rebecca ruimy a pu créer et répéter en
résidence à villennes-sur-seine sur
proposition de la ville avant de jouer à
paris
je suis monté sur le vélo là j'ai enfilé
les gants de parts et les jambes et la
gare
[Musique]